far as i know happy monday my friends
hope you had a marvelous weekend i did
but according to my legal counsel it
never happened
so ukrainian president zielinski was on
60 minutes last night
i wonder and speaking to nato did he
call them weak
in speaking to nato you called them weak
in speaking to the u.n security council
you said if you can't help you shouldn't
exist
not very diplomatic of you i wonder why
you feel the need to speak so bluntly
aggressive diplomatic when you're
working at diplomacy there are no
results
all of this is very bureaucratic
that's why the way i am talking to them
is absolutely justifiable
i don't have any more lives to give i
don't have any more emotions
i'm no longer interested in their
diplomacy that leads to the destruction
of my country
well there you go now when kovid first
broke out donald trump used the war
metaphor we're fighting a disease but
it's no different than war this was to
get america to see that we're in this
thing together
as if it were possible to share a
foxhole with nancy pelosi and rashida
talib
and just like in war truth was the first
casualty the second was your relatives
and blue state nursing homes
so now it seems we can use covid as an
analogy for war
do we want the illness to spread
a question someone should have asked the
people who created cnn plus
but also do we want a war to turn into a
world war do the wrong thing and work
and spread faster than that rash i keep
getting when i don't wipe down my old
thigh master
that was graphic
but as we saw in covid tactics change
the incoming data and data then changes
future tactics are we interpreting the
data correctly is the data reliable the
masks work or they don't that's like the
debate over what helps the ukrainians
the lockdowns are the larger commitment
it's about sacrifice do we send jets or
do we send boots on the ground
social distancing that sounds like
drones they make contact so you don't
have to but ultimately what do we want
to do
versus what do we decide to do is it
about speeding up the end of the war or
winning this war outright as an amateur
historian
meaning i only read the funny parts of
kilmeade's books
and there aren't any
for the sake of lives lost is it better
to end war fast given the fear that as
wars go on they go on and they go on the
longer they last the less likely they
end see afghanistan even when you win
you lose
the fog of war doesn't help
now looking at how the ukrainians with
our help have stymied russia the
instinct is to keep going and go for the
kill to go from ending to winning
so what are we willing to risk how do we
define winning russia is losing in
various ways putin is viewed globally as
despicable
and this is with his shirt on
ukrainians are seen as heroic and the
losses incurred by the russians are no
longer small you can see they're
changing their course maybe they're
going to be there for good occupying
like a new strain of covid and then what
here's the problem with us it's not like
we can wait to see how it's going
because pretty soon we'll be on to
something else the media can have the
collective attention span of a gnat on
bath salts and i include myself in that
but also we can't really tell who's
winning is it the patient or is it the
disease ukrainians are worthy of support
given their bravery they are the victims
you can argue about the past and even
our own culpability but russia did
invade after all but does more support
extend the war or does it help end it
that's been the question since the
beginning the sanctions failed to bring
putin to his knees the ruble is
rebounding meanwhile the cost of
sanctions is going to put the poorest at
risk this is sounding more like covet
all the time
still it makes sense to punish putin but
is it time to really engage the russian
people
do we load up the ukrainians with the
latest tech we probably are maybe it's
time to give them more but that could
always lead to more involvement more
commitment and then that leads to who
knows what
so can you handle a war with inflation
crime and democrats running wild
my thinking is you should be resistant
to measures even as you suggest them one
thing we don't want to do make things
worse
but tell that to a ukrainian woman who
has lost her husband and kids to one of
putin's missiles
and although past experiences in war
would suggest yeah we have worsened
things can this war get worse
so how's that for riding offense
i've been riding it so long i have an
ass full of splinters
but it can be the best vantage point
when making decisions that result in
death
you know i believed in the obsolescence
of ground wars a thing of the past i'd
say it's all about drones we'll fight
the wars with joysticks and basements
and so even with those russian troops
flooding the border like people getting
sick and wuhan
we really still didn't buy it the media
cried wolf so many times we thought they
were trying to wake up mr blitzer
but maybe we weren't mistaken thinking
conventional war is kind of over perhaps
we were overconfident like when i
thought that stripper was my girlfriend
maybe ukraine is one modern example to
show how ground wars don't work you see
crumpled tanks a desperate military but
without visual explanation for it
modern tech is teaching putin that he
cannot occupy a country even if he's way
bigger how can he occupy when drones
never sleep
we're now seeing a ground force getting
crushed by the offspring of radio shack
it's not really that different from that
remote controlled race car you got for
christmas and putin didn't even see it
coming
let's welcome tonight's guests
i turn him on at 6 00 p.m but he turns
me on 24 7.
yeah that was creepy
host of special report bret bear
she's covered more games than the roof
at dave and buster's former sportscaster
michelle tafoya
go bears
if you don't have anything nice to say
then you'll probably get along with her
fox business anchor dagan mcdowell
and finally she's down to earth like the
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
fox's contributor
tube
fred how you doing i'm good i'm just
really impressed that you got a thigh
master rash into a war monologue
i mean that's really
really impressive if i'm gonna do
serious topics i have to do them my way
brad you know what i'm saying and
believe me you should have seen the
alternatives if that was the one that
made the cut there were things in there
breath that would make your skin crawl
on the edit room floor yes i'd like to
read them to you after the show if you
don't mind thanks we're still on right i
think so yeah okay you know you have the
directions my assistant will pick you up
and drop you off at the same place
we'll have you blindfolded so you don't
know where the hot tub is oh dear yes
can you you are like you're the you're
you know you're a vet in the news
business
can you make heads or tails in this war
in terms of momentum i go backwards and
forwards
today i'm thinking
russia moving away from uh
kiev they lost and now they're gonna
have to do another thing but then i go
like they could easily win it i don't i
don't know where to go
i think that's that's right and and it's
really tough to see on the ground we've
been very fortunate we have reporters
who've been out and we've paid a price
for that at fox obviously um but the
you can't see
all of the stuff that's happening
through ukraine you can see that
ukrainians won in kiev they pushed
russians out but now they're regrouping
and they're going to the east so i think
it could be just a matter of time what
zielinski's saying at every media
possible and they talk really slow on 60
minutes yes very deliberate exactly but
um but he's saying i need the weapons
now to keep this going this momentum and
i i agree with you you can't say who's
going to win yeah it's it's just
unknowable until it happens and then
yeah i don't know and then everybody can
say i knew it was going to happen
michelle
there's
we fall into these analogies and there
is almost like i go to you with a
predictable question the sports analogy
right it's like you know we're we
there are two sides
and we get behind one side and we root
for that side and maybe we don't have a
lot invested in it but we still root for
it anyway and it's like easy for us
because we're over here because we're
over here right and we're this is the
first war that we're watching through
social media and through
real-time
interviews and pictures but i love
what zielinski said about the un i'm
going to read you a quote and i want you
to tell me if you know who this is
i discovered that the world should be
divided not into good and bad people
but into cowards and non-cowards 95
percent of cowards are capable of the
vilest things lethal things at the
mildest threat anyone
anyone varlam shalimov
the russian writer who was
i was going to say gallagher
but anyway he spent the better part of
15 years in forced labor camps under
stalin right so this guy knows what he's
talking about i think there are a lot of
cowards in the u.n and i love what he
said to them
what are you about yeah what are you
even doing to help here i mean i think
we know if you want to choose a side or
the other i'm choosing the side that got
attacked exactly i'm back in this side
because they did nothing to bring this
on right but what has the u.n ever done
why do they exist they eat lunches they
eat lunches they gather they tell their
nice speeches they snarl traffic
they snarl traffic in new york they
occupy our sex workers when they could
be doing other things
and in 2020 the united states spent 11
and a half billion dollars to be a
member of the u.s what is this about and
why are they not doing more and when you
consider their their human rights
council and their security council and
who is on these councils china and
venezuela
he had every right to be
un diplomatic yes it was read to him
because it's it's insane i feel like
we've we've seen this movie before we
saw it with hitler we said never again
and here we are all right
dagin
yeah you're the business mind here oh
you brought me in for that i thought i
was here to like tell some lady jokes
and make brett uncomfortable
that's later
bespoke his reputation you could do i
think you can do both okay a little bit
of business you know uh expertise and
then something really crass and
disgusting
okay okay okay i can do both what about
how much would for someone ask how much
longer can putin do this financially uh
as long as he wants because he's taking
in about a billion dollars a day from
natural gas and oil that's being sold to
the west and to europe and that is money
that's going straight into his hands to
kill ukrainians and to wage that war and
that's why
the response and it's ultimately biden
and company that are in charge of it and
it's why it's been it's less than
hapless like biden wants to make a a a
cute joke that the ruble was turned to
rubble uh actually no and that's not
funny
grandpa but it's back to where it was
the ruble is back to where it was
right about the time of the invasion if
not before because more money is going
into russia than is coming out of russia
it's it
one more thing about the money
natural gas flows into europe via
ukraine are at the highest level that
they've been since the war so the money
just keeps rolling in and to pick up on
something what are we doing
well because europe's dependent on it
and europe can't cut off russia and is
showing uh they're trying to find other
sources
saudi arabia united arab emirates and
kuwait have turned their backs on biden
and they they're actually pumping less
oil than opec plus promised they're not
even stepping up to produce what uh
europe might need not buying from russia
just one more thing i hope this is the
crude part because i'm going to quote
i'm going to quote winston churchill all
right uh money talks and count walks
okay and that's what that's what
zelinski said that was kind of better
than my quote i think i don't know i
mean
technically it can't walk but i guess
it's a it's a it's a man it's i don't
know you know kat it's you know we're
kind of doing a reassessment here of how
things are going what do you see are you
optimistic or are you pessimistic
i'm always pessimistic but that's that's
just me um
i don't know i think that
it's one of these things where i think
it's good to have a view like you have
or you worry about you know
externalities of the situation because
we tend to view things and you know a
polarized binary way and if you do say
something like hey you know you might be
concerned about getting more involved
and escalating the conflict then someone
will say to you like what if your
grandma got shot in the head with the
russian bullet i'm like well i would be
very upset right like like what do you
think of course you can realize how
brutal what is happening is but also
realize that taking certain actions
could escalate it and make it worse yeah
but he can't have then you can't have
that fear or not of fear that concern
keep you paralyzed in action i think the
the fear of nuclear war is a thing that
people
rely on but it is a real concern
but
like we've lived with that concern for
decades decades yes so it's like this is
nothing new he could they could have
done it before all right we got to move
on hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else